yeah hello and welcome to this video
which covers round four of this year's
Tyler steel tournament so let's get
going I'm going to show you some
highlights of this round and I'm not
going to look at all the games just to
focus on the most important things the
game yeah let's start with the games I
don't look at in detail
there was the game harikrishna kayaking
which was a extremely boring affair they
trade it off all that they had in some
Italian game and also won't look at the
game Aronian apanatschi Aronian got an
interesting attacking position out of
benoni and it was really interesting at
first but then there was a situation
where both sides basically had to repeat
move sometimes it happens both sides
play sharply but then there's a
situation where not going for a draw
would actually yeah lead to we have bad
consequences and a draw as was a fair
result after 20-something moves and
there also was the game report with
white against Roy to check that also was
quite interesting but ultimately it
ended in a draw report had some chances
but again I don't want to show all games
in this year's coverage and focus on the
most important points that are relevant
for the tournament standings
I want to however I have a quick look at
some moments in the game between Geary
and Andre Kim we can go a little bit
ahead and start with this position here
on move 30 it's a very sharp situation
actually both Kings are in some danger
the black king is quite open yeah
see ideas like shaking on h8 for example
on the other hand there's also something
going on with white skin yes a pin and
the King doesn't have many squares in
fact there are some director dears here
regarding perpetual checks if you look
at this position it's white to move here
black has just played rook air-five if
white for example takes this then there
already is this perpetual check
I have muted the sounds that's not I'm
kind of used to the sounds yeah no we
have sounds okay so in the game of
course that didn't happen white wanted
to win and after b7 White's position is
excellent he should win and Gary in fact
she plays this very well up to a certain
point here for example again white
cannot just yeah go for simple promotion
like check check and a new queen because
this is again a perpetual gary thought
the right move from h4 this is very
strong it gives white some more
opportunities with the king and saves
the king position Queen to b3 now if
black would have taken this check yeah
this is all taken with a check so Queen
here King edge to again securing the
King and now activating the Queen this
was actually quite a strong play by
giving Queen b6 f3 and rook to b8 and
here we have a decisive moment in this
game
it's move 37 and Kure doesn't have much
time left he now can win the game with
the movie 5 after that black is unable
to defend against all the threats the
first important line is of black ticks
j.j this is going to be decisive now
black has no way to save this for
example check check
this is extremely strong with Queen and
rook attacking in a yeah in a very
brutal way that King won't survive if
I've what else is there what else is
there that black can do for example
Queen d8j
check again it's all coming with checks
and black won't survive yeah if five hun
is the winning move but it wasn't played
give replayed rook t2 and he with this
move let black off the hook
at the end a couple of moves later check
check
we reached this which after King e6 it's
just an equal ending so give me the play
to draw again even though he got very
close to when they just had to find this
there's one little detail this he 5 in
this position that would have won him
the game yeah I don't know what it is he
sometimes gets very close to those wins
and then there's a little something
missing for him to really make a wind
out of it the next game I want to look
at is when really against Wesley so and
we had a red opening here played by Ben
Bailey and yeah the position that they
got something or position type at least
that I have some experience and I was a
bit surprised to see that
when really here went with h3 because
you usually want to play with 94 in such
a situation I think here the position
might be equal but it gives white a
little bit more in terms of yeah chances
for an interesting game just keep the
knight on the board the general idea is
to play that night to see to sometimes
play before and do something on those
dark squares again I don't think that
right is objectively better but it gives
a little bit more in terms of
interesting play um after h3 and 97 now
I think when really was probably
concerned that c5 and e5 could be used
for the black pieces and he played d4
this is leading to a fairly yeah dry
position maybe dry is the right word
nothing much happened but black is
comfortable he has very good pieces he's
got a dark square Bishop all pawns on
light squares
it's very harmonious and the white game
is a little bit without any sting that's
not quite clear what white is doing
however the way it was played it can be
fast forward a little bit yeah like as
mentioned wasn't it better but whites
allege an sis to fight and the D pawn
was very important in that regard in
this particular position here on move 13
if it really could have played better
than he did in fact let me check it
everyone knows here but they're
completely unsorted and here he played
this Bishop c7 covering the aid and here
I think why also the engine things that
men really could have drawn the game by
taking on d3
however the important thing is that here
you don't play rook t1 and allow c4
which is great for black but you rather
go here intending to pick it up like
this so first stopping any c5c for ideas
and only then going for the pawn this is
easier yeah let's say easier quoted from
the engine evaluation that played in a
game that would have been fine for white
the equal issue he didn't do that played
b3 and got into more trouble with the
black pants now rolling forward there is
one more interesting moment and a
surprising moment in a way because here
we are move 39 and now I think why it
has still a very decent chances to draw
if I'm not mistaken here after a 3 he
decided to take this with check
but now the apron was basically
unstoppable instead what he should have
done is to just take this pawn and after
black grabs take on g6 check and go rook
g5 and I actually believe that white has
quite decent chances here to draw black
it's down to 2 points and there will be
another pawn falling it will be more
pawns traded the likelihood of white
escaping to an ending with the barrack
against Luca and Bishop I think is
fairly high here for example King e6
Luke h5 yeah now look FA this g4 so
probably something like this is going to
happen and the game continues from here
black only has the c4 pawn and I don't I
don't see black winning this I mean
currently white also has chances for
fortress just keeping this covered
forever
and also again have three to trade of
the last pawn I think it's a draw so
this might have been the decisive
mistake afterwards
so Jack was able to promote his pawn
jamyest righteous but black can just
give up this exchange Jake was now he's
so close to the immediate promotion of
the pawn so a good win here for so who's
got the second win in a row yeah but he
had a extremely lucky game against
report who basically yeah through the
whole points away and now as it is a
good win in the next round and you're
completely yeah you in it in the
tournament so now is on +2 and it has an
excellent position in the standings we
also need to check of course the game of
the world champion Magnus Carlsen
Carleton today had white against via the
Chinese hope and we got a bishops game
to Bishop c4 Castle probably went for
that because of a year in recent
tournaments had played the petrov quite
often and well we know how solid this
opening is so quite often this is an
weapon for players who want to avoid the
petrov this was played a good
alternative to the more frequently seen
knight c6 which my transpose to a
regular Italian game but often the
knight is not that great on c6 so black
is playing pawn to c6 yeah I think the
whole development here looks extremely
normal we don't need to look at this in
any detail but we have an interesting
moment now because now Calvin goes for
an interesting poor information that is
rather frequently seen in the Italian
game or in the ruler past sometimes but
you don't see it all that often
these concrete circumstances CNG form
and what is a bit unusual is that white
now has weakened those two squares quite
a bit at 45
so he's unable to prevent black from
going down so 93 and 95 often times this
kind of formation is avoided if black
and immediately used those slightly
weakened squares
however Cardenas correctly evaluated
then after Bishop takes and you form
this doesn't really play a big role he
has given up the bishop pair but the
remaining pieces for wine are fairly
active and d4 gives a bit more space in
the center it feels hard to believe that
black isn't any trouble here though this
should be rather equal position Bishop
f4 and 92 covered by Queen to f6
so King g2 and now we got dispositional
is this an equal position I am Not sure
I don't really it doesn't really feel
like black made any mistake in the first
20 Museum however if we look at this
position now after Queen c1 it feels
like white is a little bit better but
why white here has an idea the idea is
to play a for f5 and make this bishop on
g6 look a bit silly and this is a bit of
an annoyance black has to somehow
address this idea cannot just ignore it
and whatever you do will be a slight
concession however I have to say that I
don't like valleys next move I might be
wrong with this assessment I'm really
not quite sure in this game but I have
to say that I dislike the move d5 here
for black he is immediately trying to
solve this issue the specialist kind of
kind of passive but in the meantime he's
trading this one problem for another
problem and the problem is that white is
gaining space with e5
he now has yeah there was no that was
wrong
he's got those four points against three
and quite some space advantage in the
center black gets the bishop traded this
problem piece but white has gained a lot
in terms of space and he also has some
ideas may be using this actively maybe
you thought that the bishop sorry that
the knight coming to e4 was an important
factor however this is very much in
doubt the knight on e4 also is a
liability for black it is currently only
supported by the default a d5 pawn and
white can always attack this with c4 in
the game after before we come to another
critical situation before is actually
taking away squares from the noid after
white plays c4 the Black Knight does not
have a single Square to go to it seems
that in this position the best defense
is to move f6 attacking the spawn but
after takes in 96 I think white is also
having a slight advantage that only six
is a bit annoying this Knight c5 is in
the position it's not much fun to play
this with black it's definitely a bit
better for white in the game f6 was not
played my event for g5 and after this he
probably is into some serious issues
c4 was played attacking the base here
for the night the anchor point for the
night yeah
how should black defend now it's already
quite critical the best might be
something like taking and then yeah
employ a sit and wait - gm7 or something
like that all right what is Knight f5
note that this looks active but it has
absolutely no square there's no square
this knife can go - maybe there's
something else there what he can do he
can stay with this maybe white here
white has this interesting move also
going for some yeah forcing some sort of
decision Knight a5 and CD 5 this Knight
has no square has depth why it is
seriously better him but in the game why
he played c5 and after that it's
immediately gone Knight d5 now is
extremely strong threatens this looks at
the pond threatened C takes d5 this is
now in fact losing for black he took
them and now has an issue C takes d5 is
also on with the knight being trapped
after this and see d5 already why he
resigned he has no playable move after
rook takes this Knight c7 and now all
black pieces are hanging he loses yeah
fool minor piece a very thing in my book
at least surprisingly quick win for what
I mean it started from a position where
you think nothing is going on more or
less like here you think nothing is
going on
and then somehow here white gotta learn
something and then like fell apart
extremely quickly extremely quickly I
think this game also shows a bit that ye
is not yet the most maybe resourceful
and and stubborn the
especially in passive positions where
you would just have to sit and wait and
in a good in a good way
[Music]
he's more of an attacking player was
great with his own initiative when he
can calculate lines that are actually
going forward for him very good game
though by cars very typical game it kind
of looks like nothing happens and all of
a sudden he's got a big advantage so the
world champion is also on +2 after he
had beaten in an earlier game avoid to
shack in the night off so a good
tournament situation also for the world
champion yeah but what does +2 mean is
that the tournament lead or not this can
only be answered by looking at the game
re-bond here with white against early
enough let's have a look
we had a Queen's Indian defense with a
three the Petrosian system and the line
that was played or something that was
quite popular by me 15 years ago yeah
this disposition type was seen a quite a
bit back then not so much nowadays
nowadays we have most games in the
Queen's Gambit and not so much in the
Queen's Indian mostly a matter of
fashion I don't want to look at this
face of the game that that much detail I
think it's fairly normal looking I mean
black probably has equalized what I
don't like however is how Adi Bond
places from here I mean I think he just
has an equal position and sometimes you
should just keep it simple and wrap the
game up for example there was nothing
particularly wrong with just taking
everything here and put the rook on d1
this is a position that you should
absolutely never lose with white maybe
he did not want to play in such a simple
way and try to try something but I mean
there is nothing to try here it is just
equal so okay the plate like this which
is not amiss
take or anything it just it plays on in
a way that you don't really see where
this is going
yeah h5 by alien north and surprisingly
g3 was the reply
don't it move that I would have thought
of
yeah offhand it looks a little bit like
yeah h5 okay please play g3 so that I
have h4 later it's a little bit
surprising it's not a big deal yet but
still was surprised by the move yeah
here also there was a fourth which was
maybe a little bit better than Bishop a
- you know I'm not quite sure what the
purpose of those maneuvers is why not
just trade everything on c6 like
mentioned earlier and make it draw
anyway it continues and there's nothing
bad happening to watch even when he took
on edge for a little bit later yeah
nothing much was going on however early
enough now plays it in a way that at
least set some problems and there is a
crisis a little bit later we can go a
couple of moves ahead we see that black
has gained to the a pawn so he has this
outside passer which is something at
least where you can hope for something
but in this ending it was all about one
particular position
this one here white it seems can draw at
least that's what the engines evaluators
like if white plays the move c4 white
tries to know hey quickly go over to the
a pawn it looks extremely risky still
because black if we continue this line
black gets this
King c3 g6 before the five takes q c5 it
still looks bad because of blacks
activity but it seems that
he has no clear way forward him white
still has to sleep on I think this is
going to be a draw at least that's what
the engines give as I mentioned after
long calculation and that also would
with you and I'm expect to draw him he
did not play that he played the blues f3
and it seems that after this note that
is move 40 the ever critical move 40
that after this the position is probably
lost
kingi 7 and now the very strong move f5
that activates black enormously and
ascending yeah I think this was very
nicely played by Ali enough now he's
going to pick up pawns and black has got
now two passports that are relatively
far apart from one another and those far
power points are always very difficult
to hold the only really remarkable thing
is the the winning motif which is pretty
nice we can forward to that yeah here we
are close to the final move of the game
black to play and win no black wants to
make his two pawns count and he has a
nice tactical winning idea by taking
here and play a two and the white
position here is completely overloaded
there's the threat of promoting and
after this the e pawn will decisively go
to e 1 and get a new queen so what does
that mean for the tournament's ending
Elian off has won is his third game him
it was black and he's leading the
tournament alone now with three and a
half out of five which is an excellent
result he has not yet played the
highest-rated class he has not yet
played card for example and the
followers are cowards and so they both
have both have two plus two and after
that a couple of guys with a plan
plus one score so we are now heading to
the first rest day after four rounds the
Wednesday is off for the players and the
tournament will continue on on Thursday
with round five I hope you enjoyed the
coverage of this round thanks for
watching